[Music]
what's up y'all welcome to roofing with
griffin doing it uh
in a hotel room this week but
first i want to say uh visit
expressvpn.com
griffin you can get an extra three
months free
on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-f-v-p-n
dot com slash griffin for three
three
months
all right let's start the show
don't got uh this is my singing mic but
i'm on the road so it's just a little
bit of whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
welcome to river
wow
all right guys thanks for uh listening i
didn't have an episode last week man i
did not have an episode last week
because i was in canada yeah i went to
canada um
shout out to canada house of comedy
uh you know they they just got back to
full capacity
and you know canada it's what a hassle
to get into the country man canada like
you know this whole thing
you know you got to get this pcr cova
test to get into canada that costs money
then you get there of course you have to
be vaccinated
and then to leave the country you have
to get another test which was another
100 something dollars i feel like this
is a racket man i feel like people are
making money off the vaccine these drug
companies they're making their money
and then now they're making this money
off these uh covet tests you're just
like what the hell so it's just such a
hassle i mean you know it makes it where
you just don't want to travel but you
know when you travel for work it is what
it is but even even like a regular
person and you just you barely scraping
it together to get some money together
to to travel to visit family or whatever
it is like that now you gotta add an
extra
almost 300 extra you have to add just to
travel it's a lot it's it's uh
damn it's a lot man
so but it was fine
uh you know the canadian crowds were
cool shout out to everybody out at the
house of comedy i mean it was cool i'm
going to miami improv this coming week
uh so check me out you know you can go
to airgriffin.com check out the schedule
and
uh it is what it is so come check me out
there you know okay i mean tampa now
side splitters was fine a lot of rather
a lot of fun shows i'm i'm having out
here in florida so i'll be in florida
again next week so let's see how
how that goes but yeah you know the
traffic i feel like i say i feel like
it's a racket like excuse me you
you need these things it's kind of like
insulin
okay
insulin people that need insulin they
need it
they have to have it
and people take advantage of that and
they're price gouging it
but i don't
think that insulin is bad or they're
doing something
shady to come up with this you know this
stuff
and
that's how i feel about the co the
vaccines and the you know taking the
cova tests like those things and of
themselves i think are fine
uh but the way people profit off these
things is what i just it just baffles my
mind man like why do people have to
make so much money
off a necessity a thing that you know
you're trying to say is about health and
safety but just seems like a money grab
seems like a big racket and it just
ticks me off man
i don't know just ticks me off
i'm not gonna have a big long episode
this week uh
i had
man it's tough like living in these
times because
my parents my parents got coveted i
don't know how they got it i don't know
what happened
so like before i was going to canada it
was like this whole thing man because
my
so they got to covet they'd been
quarantined for 10 days and every time i
talk to my stepfather i feel like he was
he didn't sound good you know what i
mean and i didn't remember that he had
like he has asthma and he's prone to
getting uh
pneumonia and that kind of stuff so i
had completely forgot about that bit but
you know they're vaccinated my mom
didn't show any symptoms at all which
was dope
but you know my mom got dementia so
so then i get a call like it's a day
before i'm about to leave to go to
canada and it's a whole big rigmarole i
just got the kova test i'm just you know
i'm just i'm not you know getting myself
prepared you have to have passport and
then another thing too when you go to
canada you have to like there's this app
this extra app where you have to fill
out all this information upload
vaccination all this stuff that you have
to have this extra like it's called air
can or whatever it's called something
can
when i got to canada they were supposed
to scan it nothing they didn't ask for
it it wasn't even a thing coming or
going so that pissed me off so anyways
you know i'm going on this trip i'm
ready to go on the trip and then i get a
call from my stepfather he's like eric
uh he's like listen i'm in the hospital
like he went to the doctor because he
wasn't feeling well and then the doctor
assessed him and was like we got to take
you to the emergency room so now my
stepfather's in an emergency room with
lingering effects of covet my mom's by
herself
with dementia
and she thinks you know like she don't
really she
thinks she's gonna go home to you know
she's waiting for him to oh come take me
home even though she's home you know
it's just a whole thing so now i'm
trying to decide oh man what do we do i
don't necessarily want to go over there
and like be with my mom considering she
she might i don't i'm not trying to get
covered right but at the same time it's
your mom what the hell do you do it's so
difficult so
they actually have where they live they
have like um some services available
like there's a like a contractor that
you know you could get and they have
these people that come in and a lot of
people at the place where my parents
live they use this service you know it's
by the hour and you can like have
someone come in and help and i didn't
know this but my stepfather has used it
before she's you know he had somebody
had to go get surgery and i think i was
out of town and he had somebody come
watching you know and she's actually
fine with these people she don't even
really understand what's going on so
she's just kind of like oh this is cool
here's a person here hey how you doing
you know and she in her mind might be
thinking oh this is my girlfriend
so-and-so and so
you know i'm still nervous i'm not sure
what's the right thing to do like what
is the right thing to do do i cancel the
trip
i just cancel the trip you know but i
just have a problem with that too just
because of how i am i think i i believe
in living up to your responsibilities i
believe in like finishing you know doing
when you have obligations you should
fulfill them uh no matter what's going
on you you if you can do it you should
do it you can find a way you don't have
to always hide behind the excuses of
like well it's a family emergency or
it's this or that i think you can find
ways to do things it's just the way i am
you know it's no it's no right or wrong
you know there's people out there who
are like it's always family first and
you like drop everything and i
understand that sentiment too uh but i'm
i'm about looking at the whole picture
and being like how can i accomplish all
these things because they're everything
is important but anyways
you know the lady comes and she's with
her and then like you know i go visit i
have to go visit her i go visit him
because i want to give him his phone
charger and then like you know i get my
mom's phone and she don't even have the
phone on you know she got three purses
you know she got a person in a purse in
her purse with a wallet and her phones
and a thing and it's not even on it
don't even work you know so i have to
turn the phone on and then it's just
like i look at the phone and it just
makes me sad because like
you know
you know i go to like the app i go to
like the contact app for my mom to
contact because i don't see i try to
type in my number and it looks as if
uh
yeah i'm not even in her phone and so i
look at my contact i look at my number
oh it is a contact but what happened was
in the in the name section like where it
says first name
there's this whole long paragraph of
writing my mom did like as if she was
sending me a message but in the contact
app so that made me super sad like it
just reminded me once again about how
like you know
when people get to mention this guy said
they're not all there they just don't
have the understanding of what's going
on so i'm reading my mom's contacts and
i'm just like i'm just heartbroken
because i'm just like oh my gosh she
can't even
let me not get emotional
anyways
so i i fixed the phone up i erased some
contacts it shouldn't be there i feel
like and i you know i charge her phone
because i want her to have her phone you
know uh
just just also just to have it on for
the location like i want to track her if
i need to she decides i'm going to walk
you know she take your phone
and then maybe i could track her you
know
so but she seems to be fine she was in
good spirits i wrote i had to write down
on a piece of paper i wrote down mike is
in the hospital he's not feeling well
stay put he'll be back in a few days
it's okay trust me it's eric you know
and then she kept hey is michael laying
down she kept saying that is he in the
other room i was like no mom look at
this note and she kept reading the note
and then eventually it was like she was
like oh yeah mike's in the hot oh she
was like oh that's not good you know and
then but i felt like she got it you know
so then i went to go visit mike and then
i'm checking i call
nobody answers the phone now the nurse
is there now this the
caregiver is there and so
you know nobody's answering the phone so
then i have to turn around and go back
you know what i mean like i turn around
and go back and then i find out that
they had just gone down to the cafeteria
and they took her for a walk and this
kind of stuff and i was like oh okay
and then like you know i'm calling the
next day to see
she's like hey everything's fine and i'm
like all right i felt like she was good
you know then i then now i had to check
on my stepfather and you know he's
he's laid up in the hospital but he just
needed to get oxygen because and
antivirals and and antibiotics and
because they were worried that he was
going to get some sort of viral
infection and get pneumonia like it
wasn't life-threatening in terms of like
to covet but it was
this was this lingering stuff and so i'm
sitting here just like you know and then
you have to have this kind of like frank
discussion you know my stepfather he's
like 30-year
um navy reserve and you know
he he he's a good dude really good dude
you know i love him a lot for just who
he is and what he's done for my mom
but you know he's sitting here and he's
telling me like he wants to have the
discussion like look i want to be
cremated
i want to i don't want a big service or
anything like that and i'm just thinking
to myself oh man dude like
this is what you have to deal with you
know you get to an age where
either your parents can handle it and
they want to talk about it you know
they're going to tell you hey here's the
life insurance policy here's where it is
here's where all the stuff is you know
he was just having this frank discussion
with me about like look here's where the
life insurance stuff is you know here's
this and that you know and i just it
really like my heart went out to him
just because like how practical he could
be and even like when i was calling him
i'm at the place and he's like i go what
about her medications you know and he's
laid up in the hospital with tubes in
this thing and he's on the phone with me
going okay on the first shelf to the
left is her medication for this her
medication for that and i'm just like
damn this dude is like straight up
taking care of my mom you know and i
felt a little guilty you know because
i'm out here living my life trying to do
stuff and you know i just it's just hard
for me like if i'm being 100
it's hard and i feel like sometimes i
avoid it i'm avoiding it because
you know i'm an only child single parent
it's been my mom my whole life
see
okay
you know
y'all gonna have me up here crying on my
podcast
uh i guess we laugh so we don't cry but
anyways
you know
it's just one of those things so we're
sitting here having this discussion
about it and i just know i go i'm put in
this situation where like i have to take
care of it you know i know this like i
know his wishes he said to me
i don't want if they have to use a
defibrillator i want him to use it one
time and that's it and i'm like damn he
like straight up like i he don't want to
be a burden he's just like boom so i'm
just like all right i know their wishes
i know my mom's like this too she don't
want to be in a machine you know what i
mean so i just go okay so i have to take
on that you know and i'm like okay it's
cool
but you know it's like all these things
you have to think about uh that is tough
and it's like you know
something like covet slaps into your
life and it's like it just propels you
into different stratosphere thinking and
and it's not necessarily the the the
cause you know like again if you if you
have pre-existing conditions like asthma
and this kind of stuff something like
cova doesn't help and it's going to take
you down a dangerous road uh but you
know there's other things too like you
know he's got to lose some weight he's
got to get him you know he's got to try
to be as healthy as he can so he can
have a you know great quality of life
for the rest of his life you know
so you know that happened but i i
actually ended up going on the trip
because i felt
again to get back to it he
he it wasn't life-threatening and he was
like they just were keeping him there
for precautions he wanted to make sure
he was getting oxygen so now he has the
oxygen machine so he's telling me like
i'll be home by friday that the people
are very great that work with
my mom and so it was like all right i
think we're good so i went on a trip and
i just was calling talking to him
talking to her and it you know it worked
out i went on a trip because you have to
compartmentalize man
when you have responsibilities you have
to compartmentalize
because if you're thinking about
everything all the time it's just
overwhelming and you won't even know
what to do it yourself sometimes you
have to
realize that all of these things are
separate and the only connection is you
but they are all separate and they can
be dealt with separately
some things could be like a huge
it's like you know pressing issue
but other things are not but just
because one is pressing it doesn't mean
they're all pressing and you have to
remember that just take one step at a
time and try to figure out uh
how to handle
you know your business because it could
be
like i say man
it's like
these these times right now it's it's
just
daunting
it could be overwhelming so
i feel like we had like once i got past
the initial like what the hell am i
gonna do and i was thinking the worst
i calmed myself down and it was like all
right
now i gotta when these things come up
now we gotta take it one step at a time
and just like sort of relax
and that actually brings me into
uh one of our sponsors for today which
is uh better help you know better help
uh betterhelp.com
griffin
uh you know let me get my ipad out over
here for you guys because i'm on the
road
you know that so there's a lot of things
like you know better always talks about
what interferes with your happiness well
you know what interferes with your
day-to-day what are those things that
you having trouble dealing with and
whatever stresses and anxieties and you
know i i highly recommend therapy man i
mean they really will point you
sometimes in the directions you weren't
even thinking of
and it really just helps you process the
feelings that you have like get in touch
with your feelings
why are you depressed why do you have
stress how does it make you feel to have
anxiety what's going on in your
relationship how does it make you feel
and you can just really get to the root
of it and this person will help you
navigate you know it's convenient it's
professional it's affordable um
you know and they have so many
they're getting new therapists in the
program every every single every single
day that you know it's not a crisis line
it's not even self-help guys it's a
professional counseling done securely
online
anything you share is confidential it's
convenience professional it's affordable
so
like i say guys i want you to start
living a happier
healthier life today and as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp.com
griffin for 10 off your first month
all right cool
um
what else did i want to talk about so oh
we put this over here so you guys don't
see it thank you for listening everybody
make sure you catch me on daily on
twitch i'm still doing that a lot
twitch.com twitch.tv slash air griffin
gaming so check me out on that i'm doing
that all the time
um i also wanted to talk about i want to
talk about a couple of movies that i saw
so i would do my best not to spoil but
there might be some spoilers
but i don't know
uh
let's talk about i first i saw the
eternals all right this marvel
this marvel movie the eternals you know
um
let me look it up here so i could just
see
let me just see what
let's look at some stuff yeah okay so
you know it stars a bunch of people man
you know it stars a bunch of people uh
i don't know harry styles was in there
yeah angelina jolie kit harrington selma
hayek you know
um just you know just a lot of different
types of people too
and you know it's like the next phase of
the marvel
universe right
and they're trying to launch into
something else and this is like you know
they have this great backstory and all
this stuff about the eternal so the
eternals are these like
you know eternal
powerful beings who are
you know were sent here by this
celestial sort of god-like
figure that you know is watching over
earth and making sure that these evil
creatures
don't devour the earth you know that's
what you're led to believe and these
eternals are are there until they're
taken away and so they've been there
apparently seven thousand years all
right
so and then it's you know uh overall i
thought the movie was okay
you know i i didn't think it was great
it was no end game it wasn't like that
but you know i felt like oh this is a
great jumping off point for the next
phase of what they're going to do in the
marvel universe obviously there's
everything still connected they're still
gonna like draw people in from the tv
shows from the other movies leading up
to some big thing again you know
and so you know the story is great i
mean the actors were great i'm not you
know i thought the performances were
great but the movie didn't blow me away
but i i do recommend watching it
especially if you're a mcu fan
all right now let's talk about now this
is a very nuanced discussion i'm about
to have
okay uh it's very like the thing about
the eternals where i'm watching it and
and i know
look you're either i don't know where
you are in your mind state all right
some of us
are still like i'm i'm older i'm almost
50 so
you know i i remember a time when people
talked about race a lot where race was a
factor in everything and then i have
this ethnic mom this uh immigrant woman
from another place comes to the united
states and she dealt with a lot of
racism she did she dealt with a lot also
being a woman and all that kind of stuff
okay
so
i'm i'm i'm a person that i still notice
these kinds of things so
the change in society that's happening
right now hasn't been normalized so
therefore
i'm still one of these people that i
notice
when it's not like it normally is
um
and you know when you look at tv from my
whole life
you look at tv it's predominantly white
everything's white
you know every show you watch
most of the stars are white there's
occasionally whatever you have you have
some out you have some other shows you
have your martins you have your you know
uh the wire you have these shows where
there are
other types of people in the shows but
they they stand out because they're so
few and far between so we just get used
to like you know when i grew up it was
bewitched it was i dream of genie it was
uh leave it to beaver it was like it was
just so many it was like so you just
look at that and you go oh well tv's
supposed to be white it's just what you
you're just used to it you know and when
you're a person of color you have to
enjoy it because there's nothing else to
enjoy so i liked seinfeld and friends
and frasier and all these shows but i
also enjoyed martin and and you know you
know in living color and other shows and
but i still of the mindset of that state
that you know i'm used to things being a
certain way so the reason why i say that
is when it's not like that sometimes you
kind of get like whoa what's going on
and that's because it's not normalized
now you could be like me and you said
you go i'm a comic too so i over analyze
everything so you know i see this and i
might be like oh here we go this is here
they're trying to the diversity for the
sake of diversity so that's sometimes
where i come from i come from this like
why you know are you just making things
diverse just to make people feel good
and and i started to think about that to
be like well there's actually nothing
wrong with that like like we've it's
been normal to think that like superman
is supposed to be white you know why
why why why he's supposedly from a
distant planet but he's still white like
you don't have to be white you can make
superman anybody it could be anybody you
want but you know
and once that becomes normal and we
don't even look at it like that
that's when we'll be able to advance
more in society but right now we still
notice those kinds of things just being
honest you know just being honest even
it don't even have to be racial things
man i was watching the commercial the
other day for huggies and the baby had
glasses
what
like
even i i wear glasses and i thought this
was [ __ ]
i it made me feel like they were having
a board meeting and somebody was like
can should we have a white baby and
someone in the back was like glasses and
they were like good one there you go i
mean it just felt like that but it
doesn't mean it was that that's just how
i interpreted it you know and so right
now again there's a big push you know
you see a lot of you see a lot of asian
stuff now even though it's been around
for a long time you know i i love a lot
of korean movies and all this kind of
stuff you know what i mean it's but now
it's like there's like a push just being
more like we're going like oh let's
appreciate this you know and it
shouldn't be an issue like when you see
an asian woman in a movie it shouldn't
be like ooh it's an asian woman you know
but if you feel like that you're not
there yet we're just not evolved yet
there are some people younger people who
might look at stuff and don't even think
about this ever it's not even an issue
they're just looking at it and they
might be like i don't think she's a good
actress or oh i don't think that's the
right casting and they're never thinking
about race and that kind of stuff and
good for you i think that's where we're
all trying to get but it's just not
normalized yet right
that being said
when i watch the eternals
i get the impression
that
disney
is trying to
put out an agenda
it didn't feel natural to me for a lot
of reasons one because of being because
of
all the social issues that have been
going on and two
i'm a nerd that i have to be able to
suspend my disbelief and if i see some
nonsense on the screen i don't care
about race none of that stuff i'ma point
that out i'm at war with these two
points right now and that's what i'm
saying it's a nuanced discussion
uh
because on one side it's like they got a
gay black guy
two asians
a deaf girl
a latino
um a arab
someone of like sort of arab descent
it's like
you want to talk about a hodgepodge man
i was like
i saw this and i was like okay what are
we doing what's going on here all right
so then you just kind of go you have a
feeling of like okay disney i see what
you're trying to do and then there was a
whole thing about like they didn't let
the eternals was not allowed in certain
countries around the world because
there's a gay kiss in the in the movie a
black gay kiss too by the way so that's
an added layer and so there were certain
there were certain arab countries that
were like you need to edit it and then
you know marvel disney's like nah we're
not going to edit it so you know you
have you have that issue but you just
kind of go
you go okay i get it you make are you
making a statement or whatever the thing
you're trying to do all right you did it
you put out the movie you put these
people in it all right now the nerd part
of me is like
what
like the nerd part of me guys the nerd
part of me is
the eternals are 7 000 years old right
why is selma hayek talking in a latino
accent
that hasn't been invented yet
that like i couldn't get past that
i couldn't get past there here on earth
for seven thousand years in prehistoric
times uh you know the beginnings of
civilization and she talking in a modern
ass latino accent i mean i know that's
her accent i'm just saying
i'm looking at her as this figure in the
movie i i i know it's selma hayek and
that's who she is but i'm saying for
this movie was that the best casting
that that that's where i'm going with it
where i was kind of like what why like i
don't get why this celestial being made
these people
like this
like
why did he create them
like this
was there a thought process he was like
okay we're gonna make this one black and
this one's gonna be like
it it kind of took me out of it the nerd
the nerd in me it took me out of it and
so i couldn't really wrap my brain
around it or feel good about it i just
was i just was constantly thinking about
that you know and so
that's you know that's on me you know
that's on me being like i say being a
nerd
you know what i mean like
it doesn't mean
you know it doesn't mean like this is
right what i'm saying or or you know
it's just i'm just i'm just pointing out
that
we're just at a time right now where
we're at a crossroads and maybe in 10
years
we this won't be an issue no matter
who's in the movie whether they're
transgender black white whatever it is
even if something's all white we'll look
at it and be like oh this makes sense
we're not going to be sitting here in
the crowd being like oh man another
all-white thing because i'm not like
that sometimes i'm like yeah this should
be all white because they this is a show
about people living in a certain place
they all white there like let's be
accurate like i'm talking about artistic
integrity uh i believe in that first as
an artist myself so sometimes it's hard
when these social issues come in and get
in the way of the art
uh you know what i mean so that's what
i'm talking about with that but that
being said i still think it was an
enjoyable movie uh you know i probably
i'll watch it again when it's on uh you
know it'll be on disney plus i'll watch
it again like that i thought it was
really enjoyable you know still to me
right now the most enjoyable movie i've
seen in a long time was dune like when i
was in canada i went and watched it
again
in the theater and it's such a great
theater experience so i do highly
recommend you go see that and go see the
eternals all right go see the eternals
that's my
my little rant on
the eternals
okay guys now i want to talk about
my sponsor my new sponsor it's my new
sponsor what's my new sponsor expressvpn
expressvpn
it's like you know when you're searching
for something online and you don't want
you know prying eyes you get
express vpn i know what most of you are
probably thinking why don't you just use
incognito mode and i do be using
incognito mode sometimes only just
because you know when you close whatever
you were looking at it's gone right but
incognito mode does not hide your
activity it doesn't matter what mode you
use or how many times you clear your
browser history and so if you want to
just
browse privately without people getting
all on you
expressvpn is the way to go it doesn't
matter who your internet service
provider is isp is in the us can legally
sell your information to ad companies so
that sucks another reason to use express
vpn is an app that reroutes your
internet connection to your secure
servers so your isp can't see the sites
you visit expressvivian vpn also keeps
all of your information secure by
encrypting 100 of your data with the
most powerful encryption encryption
available all right so protect your
online activity today with the vp vpn
rated number one by cnet visit my
exclusive link expressvpn.com
griffin and get an extra three months
free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
griffin
expressvpn.com griffin to learn more
back to the show
all right
so
the next movie that i saw and i saw this
out in canada too that i wanted to talk
about was the new double o seven i think
it's time to kill i think that's what
it's called let me look this let me look
it up time to
kill is that what it is no time to kill
or is it no time to kill yeah i think
it's no time to kill no
right which one is it what are you am i
saying right like you guys are you're
not live
no time to die that's what it is
oh it just it just felt like they're all
you know yeah no time to die guys no
time to
die
and this is the last of daniel craig's
um time as double oh seven
um and let me see what how and so i want
to talk about
you know how i feel about this
um
let me i mean i actually go to daniel
craig because i want to see
all the james bond movies that he's done
uh sorry i'm not looking at the camera
here guys um no time to die uh it was
i don't know man
i don't know
so
let's see
you had 2006
casino royale i believe that was his
first
bond appearance right
yeah i think it was his first bond
appearance um
that was a great movie you know but
sometimes all the james bond's movies
kind of like blend into each other and
it's hard to it's like a family it's
like family guy where all the cutaways
you don't even remember what episode you
just remember all the cutaways that's
how i feel about these bond movies you
know i've been watching james bond
movies my whole life my favorite james
bond is still roger moore i liked roger
moore and you know the jaws the the guy
with the gold teeth was his you know big
nemesis you know i liked roger moore
and then um
my mom loved sean connery that was her
favorite james bond
and i liked um i didn't like the guy
after that i forgot his name
but then like the dude from uh remington
steele you know you know he was great
pierce bronson but he was always
supposed to be james bond when he but he
couldn't get out of his remington steel
contract and then he finally did it but
at that point it was like whatever you
know so
um
i don't know
i'm just like i say i'm really trying to
decide
maybe i should look up like the james
bond movies in order you know james
bond movies
you know let's see if they have like
james bond movies in chronicle
chronological order oh they do actually
this is actually great
yeah wow
okay yeah so die another day was pierce
bronson's last one
okay so then casino royale was 2006.
that was a good one then it's quantum of
solace which was 2008
and then they started to do this thing
where like it was like the movies were
sort of like
sequels
see i like the james bond movies where
they're just standalone it's like here's
a world killing villain
who we have to like james bond needs to
stop
and you know he's got gadgets and he's
just beautiful women and you know the
world changed the world changed so now
it's this whole thing now where it's
like let's not make these women objects
and we always have to make them you know
something great about them and i'm all
for that it's fine you know uh but it's
like a throwback to
the old movies
it's like um i don't even know what to
even say about that i mean it is what it
is i got i have no problem with women
being beautiful on screen you know what
i mean like dude like if that if that's
what they are on screen that's what they
are on screen you know because
regardless of how strong or powerful you
want to make the woman on screen she
ain't ugly okay
let's just be 100 so artists you can say
whatever you want about how you want to
portray women
they always find on screen okay
in these kinds of roles so
it is what it is
all you're doing is making them better
we're looking at them we're still
looking at them the same and they're
like damn she's fine
and she could kick people's ass you know
it's like that's just you just adding to
the the the love affair but like let's
not act like you're doing something all
like oh
you you know it ain't it ain't
a fat bomb chick okay
and then a chick with a lazy eye or a
pimple on her forehead it's still
they still baddies all right let's just
be real
so uh you know you got skyfall where
they had this like
specter
you know it was like they're connected
i'm not a fan of the connecting of the
movies i couldn't follow the plot i
didn't know what the hell was going on
it was like it was to me it was like too
dramatic too
and this is how this movie was too by
the way
even though it was kind of both like
this this no time to die kind of had a
throwback
bond feel to it
uh the gadgets uh the the stunts the you
know it really had a throwback feel to
it for daniel craig's final
uh james bond movie but it
it just i don't know it was missing
something and i think that what it is is
this this
it was this story that was hard to
follow
i don't know why there was this like
shadow organization
that in this movie just vanishes by the
way like how they got rid of it i was
like you did all that and now they're
just gone and now there's like a super
villain played by uh what's his name
remy malco
remy is that how you say his name
uh yeah rammy matt malik or ma i don't
know
r-a-m-i-m-a-l-e-k
you know you know he's from mr robot he
won an oscar for the queen movie uh he
was great in it though he was actually a
really great actor he's a really great
actor everybody was pretty good in this
movie like everybody was good
you know it was that's what i'm saying
it was serviceable movie uh the action
was great daniel craig was at his best
you know he's actually a really great
actor too they're all they're all really
great actors it's just the story was
like
you know it was
you know i don't even want to you know i
don't it's hard to even give anything
away because if you've been following
the other bond movies you know about
this shadow specter and then they
captured the leader and he's in prison
now and somehow he's still involved and
it's just they really like really
reached on this story
sort of like it's like a lot of this
backstory about the the james bond's
girl you know uh
played by leia sadhu i don't even know
how to say her name i hope i'm saying
her name right but you know yeah she's
dope
uh and she you know it's kind of more
about her story and then they got a new
double 07.
you know they got this new double 07
played by
uh
lashanna lynch
so lashana lynch is the new double 07 in
this movie you know they call her you
know she cuz because because daniel
craig his james bond james bond sort of
retired for all the stuff he did in the
last two movies with this spectre
nonsense
so now she's the new double 07. so i
thought to myself wait a minute is this
how you're introducing the next james
bonds movies so you've decided to go
with a black woman as the new double 07.
and does that mean james bond is gone
like i don't know how to do it you know
i i i wasn't sure if they were retiring
james bond or and they're if they're
totally going into a new era that james
that the double-oh-seven is going to be
represented by this badass black woman
and she she's dope but at the same time
this you you go what was i saying before
about the eternals it's one of those
things where you wrap your brain you
have to wrap your brain around it like
are you progressive and you're like ooh
she's great and this is gonna be good or
are you one of these people like me
that's a little cynical where you're
just kind of like oh really you're gonna
have a black woman be james bond now
okay i see what you're doing so i'm
trying to get out of that mode not
necessarily be fully on board on the
other mode and just kind of look at it
because there's also the nerd in me that
has to look at the artistic artistic
side of it and i just go do i like this
or not and why don't i like it so you
know it gets you down a rabbit hole of
thinking about stuff and that's what
sucks about it you know that's what
sucks about the world right now so
hopefully all this [ __ ] will be
normalized and we won't think about this
in the future but i don't know if i'm a
fan of this moving forward i don't know
if that's what they were if that's what
they were doing uh they're gonna be like
well this is now and then they're gonna
call it james bond like what are they
gonna call it is it gonna be double 07
something is she gonna be jameela bond
you know what i mean bond
jamila bond
i actually would like that
her name was jamila
i want my tangerine coke
shaken not stirred
i mean maybe maybe that'll work so we'll
see
so she's in there and it's like you know
she's kind of fighting with james bond
because she's trying to prove herself
that she's the best double oh seven
so you know
you gotta again it's worth watching
and i thought
in the end how they you know
how they get rid of daniel craig i
thought it was well done i thought it
was i thought it was nicely done i
thought it was a great moment in the
movie i thought i was emotional i was
like oh they did their job anytime i'm
in a movie and i get emotional i'm like
all right this is good am i supposed to
be emotional right here that's great no
matter how shitty the movie is you can't
move people to emotion so
this was uh
this was one of those
you know this was one of those
moments
you know um
i don't know like
i don't know if this is a good review or
not guys i don't know how you
feel about this review but
i guess
i'm gonna give it oh and i got my rating
system now guys i just figured that out
too so
i got my rating system that we're gonna
do for the movie
we're gonna give them woo-woos
okay so for the eternals
out of five i'm giving the eternals
three and a half woo-woos
there we go so they get three and a half
woo-woos for the eternals and i thought
james bond
it's another three out of five for me
too so
[Music]
maybe the other one needed another woo
woo
for the half there you go but we figured
out so we got
three moves
for uh james bond and three and a half
for eternals
because i really love the disney
universe the mark the ma i'm sorry the
mcu the marvel universe so we'll see
where
that
is
going
so what else uh rachel and i have a
wedding
day
plan we got it's in june it's gonna be
in june so we got our we went and saw
the place that we want to do it it's
this really nice place i won't tell you
where but it's like it's nice
uh you know she wanted me to go
i wanted to go to and i saw it and i was
like oh this is really great i i saw
like where she's gonna how she's gonna
where she's gonna want to take pictures
and how it's gonna look and it just it
felt good but you know you know what
happens when you like actually set a
date you know i think we both were a
little nervous after that there was like
you know uh i think we had a little
tension between us because
this big daunting thing that we're
headed towards is now it's solidified
and we're moving towards it so you know
there's a lot of things you have to
think about i think we're going to do
some couples therapy and i think that's
i think that's healthy to do that kind
of stuff but i'm excited about it you
know i'm excited i already feel like our
life is already where we already feel
like we're living our life that's the
thing you know so this is a very
symbolic gesture a very
celebration of love and
uh relationship and companionship that's
what a wedding i guess is you know and
so i'm excited to do that for because
she really wants to do it too and that's
why i like making her happy and so
like she wanted this
this light machine
this i don't know what it's like a blue
light machine that you go to the thing
and you get you know
and she's she was like i want this you
know and it was so expensive but i was
like you know what
i'm doing all right
let me let me get my girl this light
machine
you know what i mean she like you put it
over your face and like you know you
know she's like i'm doing it every day
you know it's like supposed to take away
pimples and help with aging and pain and
oh it's supposed to do all this kind of
stuff that i'm going to use it too you
know but you know sometimes you got to
do that kind of stuff and i'm just
saying it because i like doing that kind
of stuff
uh
the big gestures and the little gestures
because i like seeing a smile on her
face i like
i just like seeing that
joy that whatever this thing that i'm
doing for her that she really
appreciates it you know
and when you have somebody like that
that truly appreciates you and what you
do
it just encourages you to do more things
like that uh especially if you are a
giver if you like if you're a giver
and you get joy out of giving uh i like
being around someone that's not ashamed
of
you know getting joy out of receiving
and and having appreciation so it's
really good in
a relationship when you have that
sort of thing going on but
anyway guys
a short episode this week because i'm
out like as you can see if you're
watching on youtube i'm in this weird
corner of my of my hotel room and it's
like
i did this on my iphone too by the way i
did bring my mic and my h6 zoom and i
got my you know my mic and all so i
wanted the sound to sound good but who
knows if it's even gonna sound good but
i like i i had to do an episode i didn't
do one last week my first episode off in
150 something weeks i was like you know
what i deserve a break i deserve to not
have one so but i'm back and you know
just how i usually do it i'm gonna do it
regardless
just last week was just you don't know
how hectic it was with the canada travel
but you know so i'm back this week and i
did this all on my iphone so shout out
to apple and iphone for uh you know
having such a good product that you
could do something like this on it
um
once again i'll be in the miami improv
next week
if you're listening to this like later
like because this is on the internet you
know you missed it
uh what else uh again i'm on twitch
check me out on twitch twitch.tv eric
griffin so check me out on twitch i'm on
there most days
um
what else oh you know king of this thing
too i'm like you know they announced it
you know i'm in the new
intro song you know me and stevie weeby
you know we're permanent people on
kicking this thing so check me out on
king and the sting and also check me out
on gender gen that's my other podcast so
we got gender gen kingdom sting riffing
with griffin air griffin gaming i'm out
here people i'm out here trying to make
content and bring the entertainment and
i'm also on the road a lot so check me
out on my schedule eric griffin.com
that
i have dates coming up there's again i'm
gonna be in miami i'm gonna be at the la
jolla comedy store
i want to be in la if you're in the
burbank area maybe at a club called
flappers so come check me out there then
in the beginning of the year i'm going
back to canada i'm going to edmonton so
make sure you come
and check all that out but shout out
again to the king of the stand crew
brendan and theo
uh for you know
inviting me in because they they wanted
my whatever i brought to it and you know
and shout out to all the fans that have
actually come to the shows like y'all
showing up at the shows man and i just
want you to know i appreciate that he's
a king and a sting fan of course riffing
with griffin fans love y'all y'all great
for
with griffin people i know who you are
thank you but i'm just telling you these
new people that are coming from king and
the sting they're coming out they're
coming and they're walking up to me
letting me know thank you for what you
do i love you on king of this thing and
they come and they spend the money and i
appreciate them so that's dope so we're
going to keep the train rolling keep it
moving and you know i got some guests
coming but again i'm going to be doing
this solo
and also oh
make sure you check out the fireside app
check out fireside chat app you can look
at it in the app store
because i'm doing this thing with rachel
because it's called i hate my
boyfriend's couch and it's just a
relationship show where rachel and i
talk about stuff like that when you when
when your girl hates your furniture how
do you deal with it it's just an overall
theme for like the things we'll be
talking about so sometimes it'll be i
hate my boyfriend's farts i hate my
boyfriend's clothes and it's just a
matter of like how do you discuss those
kinds of things with your significant
other so
look out for that on the fireside chat
and i'm gonna try to get those videos up
on youtube but something was happening
with the app you i would go live on the
app and it would be on youtube but then
when it when it closed th the the the
thing went private and i couldn't make
it unprivate because it was some kind of
terms and conditions it was like a weird
thing so they're working that out but
but thanks for all the people that were
watching that live on on youtube make
sure you check it out again on the
fireside app so once again this is uh
real from with griffin
i appreciate you guys being here i
appreciate the loyalty and i will see
you next week